[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
áfrica siete días aquí en france 24 este
es un magacín informativo 100% dedicado
al continente africano mi nombre es
liliana valencia y aquí damos una mirada
en profundidad los hechos de actualidad
de la semana en la cuna de la humanidad
el presidente de francia en manuel bacón
anunció su decisión de poner fin a la
operación barkan y retirar las tropas
francesas que combate a las milicias
yihadistas en la región del sahel esto
al tiempo que se confirmó la muerte de
uno de los altos mandos yihadistas
responsables del secuestro de dos
periodistas franceses en el año 2013
marruecos y españa pasan por el peor
momento de su relación diplomática en 20
años debido a que la nación
norteafricana suspendió los controles
migratorios en la frontera con la ciudad
de ceuta
el parlamento europeo acusa a marruecos
de usar la migración como una
herramienta política
y se cumplen 30 años del fin de la
partida en sudáfrica oa partir de junio
de 1991 cuando más de 300 leyes que
institucionaliza van el racismo en el
país empezaron a ser derogadas y dieron
paso a una nueva era para sudáfrica con
nelson mandela como presidente y su
política de reconciliación
iniciamos entonces con la información
aquí en áfrica siete días y empezamos
hablando de la lucha contra el yihadismo
en el sahel porque el ejército francés
confirmó la muerte del líder de al-qaeda
responsable del secuestro y asesinato de
los periodistas franceses en el año 2013
la noticia llega pocos días después de
que el presidente francés emmanuel macon
anunciara su decisión de poner fin a la
operación marcan y de retirar las tropas
francesas que ahora operan en la región
del sahel la ministra de las fuerzas
armadas de francia confirmó el deceso
del líder yihadista una extensión de
militar el 5 de junio la fuerza abarcan
detectó un ataque planeado contra un
complejo de la onu en el norte de mali
set operación esta operación llevó a la
muerte de cuatro terroristas entre ellos
se encontraba valle acv a cabo alto
mando de las milicias islamistas de al
qaeda en el magreb y responsable del
secuestro de nuestros ciudadanos y
responsable
de uno con sitio ella y es que
justamente el presidente francés
emmanuel macon anunció el retiro de las
tropas francesas de malí donde en
colaboración con los militares de ese
país
en frente a la amenaza de las milicias
yihadistas repasemos la tecnología de la
intervención militar francesa en ese
país africano
francia inició la intervención militar
en mar y en enero de 2013 a petición del
entonces presidente john conde traure
cuando una ofensiva yihadista amenazaba
la capital del país bamako se solicite
solicite y obtuve el apoyo aéreo de
francia en el marco de la legalidad
internacional de catedral de garita
internacional
mal y su pueblo no están solos en esta
lucha contra el terrorismo
terrorismo con decenas de ataques aéreos
el ejército francés se embarcó entonces
en la operación ser valenmar y en
cuestión de semanas las principales
ciudades del norte del país quedaron
liberadas sin embargo la operación duró
año y medio hasta agosto de 2014 cuando
el operativo militar francés se
transformó porque la amenaza terrorista
persistía entraron en la cooperación
militar países del sahel como mauritania
níger y chad y la misión de naciones
unidas minustah la intervención pasó a
llamarse operación barkan en total 5 mil
100 soldados franceses y 8000 malienses
han combatido en el operativo con la
presencia de 15.000 miembros de naciones
unidas con el objetivo oficial de privar
a los militantes islamistas de acceder a
medios de combate de comunicación y de
aprovisionamiento en el trópico una
verdad es utópico pensar que llegaremos
a parar todos los flujos
desde el inicio de la intervención 51
soldados franceses han perdido la vida
en malí mientras que la cifra de
malienses muertos a manos del ejército
de francia no es clara según naciones
unidas un bombardeo de la aviación
francesa mató al menos a 19 civiles que
celebraban una boda a principios de este
2021 ocho años después de intervenir
francia suspenderá la misión según
anunció el presidente francés emmanuel
macro y seguimos hablando de malí porque
un nuevo gobierno tomó posesión después
del segundo golpe de estado de nueve
meses en ese país con el coronel
golpista así mi gol está a la cabeza y
con militares en varios de los puestos
más importantes esto mientras la unión
africana insiste en pedir elecciones
democráticas en el país y un gobierno
civil definitivo
colom al así me gusta coronel así migoya
presidente de transición y jefe de
estado lo reconocemos como el gran
maestro del orden nacional de mayor
metro de sorna zona rival y el coronel
así migoya fue investido oficialmente
como presidente interino de malí el
responsable de dos golpes de estado en
nueve meses prestó juramento con una
promesa
garantizar la transición democrática dos
semanas antes había derrocado a los
líderes civiles del país un nuevo hombre
fuerte de malí llegó al poder en agosto
de 2020 a la cabeza de un grupo de
coroneles golpistas arrestó al entonces
presidente ibrahim bubacar keita y al
primer ministro busy c y luego se
dirigió a las multitudes reunidas en el
centro de bamako la capital no podemos
permitirnos ningún otro error al hacer
esta intervención ponemos al país
primero mal y primero al de a pocos en
septiembre de 2020 la junta cede al
poder a un gobierno interino presidido
por bandas o que se compromete a
organizar elecciones en un plazo de 18
meses pero en mayo el presidente fue
arrestado junto con su primer ministro y
su ministro de defensa por los militares
detenciones ordenadas por goit a un día
después banda y su gobierno dimitieron
hoy el nuevo presidente de mari debe
enfrentar las consecuencias diplomáticas
de esta segunda toma del poder en nueve
meses francia ha suspendido su
cooperación militar con el ejército de
mali mientras que la unión africana ha
suspendido a mali de su organización
cambiamos de información y hablamos
ahora la crisis diplomática entre españa
y marruecos el ministro de exteriores
del país norteafricano nacer bonita
afirmó que el gobierno español trata de
europeizar una crisis que es bilateral y
negó que la salida de ese país del líder
saharaui ibrahim ghali resolviera el
conflicto a mediados de mayo marruecos
dejó de evitar el paso ilegal de unos
10.000 migrantes incluidos cientos de
menores a territorio español en la
ciudad de ceuta en el norte de áfrica
esto en represalia porque ahora jindal y
quien busca la independencia de sahara
occidental estaba en españa recibiendo
tratamiento médico por coi 19 la crisis
diplomática ha desencadenado también una
crisis migratoria en las ciudades de
ceuta y melilla pertenecientes a españa
pero ubicadas en territorio africano en
frontera con marruecos sobre el tema
hablamos con nuestra corresponsal en
marruecos sofía catalán quien de temas
general os dio detalles de esta
información
españa y marruecos atraviesan su mayoría
de crisis diplomáticamente años y de los
estados vecinos han utilizado la
migración para saldar sus desavenencias
políticas aparentemente también tensó
tras la hospitalización en español del
líder independentista saharaui brahím
and alice que es secretario general del
frente polisario organización armada se
llevan guerra con el estado de marruecos
a más de 40 años
en este contexto marruecos después de
visitar sus fronteras una ceuta que ese
al igual que melilla una ciudad en clave
española en el norte de áfrica de
marruecos considerada territorio ocupado
más de ocho mil personas en situación de
pobreza a muchas de ellas niños sólo se
lograron entrar al enclave cruzando a
nado la frontera
de estas personas la mayoría fueron
inmediatamente expulsadas a marruecos
por parte de la policía y del ejército
españoles entre ellos muchos niños y sin
seguir ningún procedimiento legal
también entre los expulsados había miles
de migrantes subsaharianos que acabaron
siendo expertos a mente desplazados al
sur de marruecos por parte de las
autoridades de este país
el parlamento europeo le puede calificar
estas expulsiones ha condenado el cese
de la vigilancia de la frontera por
parte de marruecos país al que acusan de
vulnerar los derechos de la infancia
cabe destacar que la propia unión
europea paga cantidades millonarias de
dinero a marruecos anualmente para que
bloqueen reprima los flujos migratorios
y también a la cámara europea ha
reiterado su posición en sintonía con la
onu al respecto del status quo del
sáhara occidental cabe recordar que la
administración de los eeuu reconocía la
soberanía de marruecos sobre este
territorio y ahora el estado marroquí
busca presionar a los estados europeos
para que sigan los pasos de la
administración estadounidense por su
parte colectivos de defensa de derechos
humanos sobre el terreno denuncian a la
utilización de la vida de las personas
inmigrantes para salvar desavenencias
políticas entre los estados y también ha
denunciado que ahora mismo sigue
habiendo muchos menores en situación de
calle y totalmente desprotegido sólo en
clave de ceuta
a más de 350.000 personas se enfrentan a
una fuerte escasez de alimentos en la
región del tigre en el norte de etiopía
devastada por el conflicto con eritrea
eso según un estudio de seguridad
alimentaria de la onu la alianza de
agencias de naciones unidas asegura que
si se intensifica el conflicto en el
tigre o se obstaculiza la entrega de
ayudas la mayoría de los 5,5 millones de
habitantes de esa región podría sufrir
hambrunas
el gobierno etíope niega que haya una
grave escasez de alimentos en la región
vamos ahora el sur del continente porque
sudáfrica está conmemorando los 30 años
del fin del apartheid un sistema de
segregación que institucionalizó el
racismo por medio de la aprobación de
más de 300 leyes que privilegiaban a la
minoría blanca en junio de 1991
estarellas empezaron a ser derogadas
hasta que en 1994 en el cso mandela se
convirtió en el primer presidente negro
de este país el 17 de junio de 1991 las
tres cámaras del parlamento sudafricano
la blanca
la mestiza y la india derogaron la
última de las leyes que sostenía el
compendio jurídico del apartheid que los
recién nacidos fueron clasificados por
razas de esta forma se puso fin a cuatro
décadas de segregación racial
institucionalizada en sudáfrica un
racismo que venía de siglos atrás pero
que legalmente tuvo sus orígenes en 1902
tras el tratado de paz entre británicos
y afrikáner es antiguos colonos
neerlandeses quienes sentaron la premisa
de que el hombre blanco debe ser siempre
el amo
eran los mismos años en que había sido
fundado el congreso nacional africano el
partido político de la etnia xhosa que
desde 1912 luchaba por restituir el
derecho al voto de los africanos negros
y mestizos
justamente hace 30 años en 1991 nelson
mandela tomó las riendas del congreso
nacional africano luego de que un año
antes el por entonces presidente
frederik de klerk lo hubiese liberado de
los 27 años de prisión
por supuestamente haber conspirado para
derrocar al gobierno con mándela libre y
presidiendo el congreso nacional
africano de la parte tenía sentenciado
su final el 17 de marzo de 1992
los sudafricanos votaron masivamente un
referendo en contra de la parte de iu a
favor de que el partido de mandela
pudiera tener el derecho de competir en
una carrera presidencial y así fue en
1994 nelson mandela llegó a ser el
primer presidente negro de sudáfrica
gracias al voto de millones de
sudafricanos entre el 26 y el 29 de
abril de ese mismo año que le apostaron
a una política de reconciliación
nacional y finalizamos este capítulo de
áfrica a 7 días con la nueva canción de
la artista maliense fatoumata diawara
ella reunió a nueve mujeres de
diferentes países africanos en este
nuevo sencillo titulado hambre y con
esta buena música nos despedimos en
áfrica siete días pero antes los
invitamos a visitar nuestra página web
www puntos 24 punto com para ampliar la
información de américa latina y el mundo
en cuatro idiomas quédense con nosotros
esto estarán 24
[Música]
para vivir
la morana
muy buenas
llamar a más